ZDF heute live euch allen ein herzliches
Willkommen toll dass ihr mit dabei seid
nach dem Terrorangriff der Hamas auf
Israel ist die angekündigte israelische
Bodenoffensive bislang ausgeblieben
viele Menschen im Norden Gazas haben
ihre Heimat verlassen in den letzten
Tagen waren viele ranghohe Politiker
Staats- und Regierungschefs Diplomaten
zu Besuch in Israel haben auf
diplomatischer Ebene mit Gesprächen
versucht was zu bewegen zu besänftigen
den Konflikt zu deeskalieren am Ende
dann aber auch festgestellt eine
wirkliche Alternative zu einem
Eingreifen auf dem Boden gibt es nicht
und so bleibt auch Israel offiziell
dabei dass es eine Bodenoffensive
alsbald geben soll joaf galant der
israelische Verteidigungsminister hat es
gestern auch noch einmal ganz offiziell
bekräftigt und gesagt die an der
küstenklave stationierten Truppen werden
den Gazastreifen bald von innen sehen
das Vorhaben bleibt allerdings
risikohaft einer möglichen
Bodenoffensive für das israelische
Militär denn das Gebiet in Gaza zeichnet
ein weitläufiges Tunnelsystem aus und
zudem warnen Experten vor einem blutigen
Häuserkampf und am Ende auch vor einem
möglichen zweif frontenkrieg den Israel
dann führen müsste wir wollen deshalb
heute Abend bei uns in der Sendung
fragen wie groß sind die Risiken einer
israelischen Bodenoffensive und wollen
dazu reden mit unserem ZDF
Korrespondenten Michael beverunge der
sich aktuell im Norden jetzt befindet
mit dem nahostexperten Daniel Gerlach
und mit dem militäranalysten Hendrik
Remmel und dazu interessieren uns
natürlich wie immer hier bei ZDF heute
live auch eure Fragen eure Meinungen zu
diesem Thema die ihr uns wie immer über
die Kommentarspalten gerne schicken
könnt oder auch via Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdfde bevor wir damit aber
starten mit diesen Gesprächen wollen wir
euch ein kurzes Update zur Lage in
Israel und Gaza geben 13 Tage nach dem
Terrorangriff der
Hamas pendeldiplomatie auf Hochtouren
Außenministerin berbor heute wieder in
Israel begrüßt vom israelischen
Amtskollegen morgen wird sie in Ciro
sein bei einem von Ägypten anberaumten
Gipfel mit Regierungschefs aus der
Region und eu-ministern wir alle wollen
verhindern dass die ganze Region ins
Chaos stürzt deshalb bin ich ganz klar
an all diesen Orten in meinen
Botschaften Hisbollah darf den Libanon
nicht mit in diesen Konflikt
hineinziehen die hisbolla die andere
islamistische Terrororganisation die vom
Libanon ausagiert liefert sich seit
Tagen schon Gefechte mit Israel sie hat
angedroht bei einer Bodenoffensive in
den Krieg einzutreten ein Armeesprecher
am
Vormittag wir machen weiter mit unseren
logistischen Vorbereitungen damit die
Soldaten am besten auf die
Bodenoffensive vorbereitet
sind neue Informationen gab es von der
Armee hinsichtlich der Geiseln die im
gaserstreifen gefangen gehalten werden
20 von ihnen seien unter 18 Jahre alt
die Mehrheit sei am Leben in Raffer an
der Grenze zwischen Ägypten und den
Gazastreifen warten weiterhin dutzende
LKW mit Hilfsgütern auf Einfahrt am
Mittag war un Generalsekretär guterisch
auf der ägyptischen Seite vor
Ort diese Lastwagen sind nicht nur
Lastwagen sie sind eine
Lebensader sie sind der Unterschied
zwischen Leben und Tod für so viele
Menschen in
Gaza Gaza
morgen frühestens sollen endlich die
ersten Lastwagen hinein
dürfen ja unser ZDF Korrespondent
Michael bwerunge der ist in den Norden
Israels heute gereist und wenn ich das
auch richtig auf dem Schirm habe steht
er jetzt für uns in Kirjat
schmona jenem örtlichen nördlichen
Grenzort der evakuiert werden soll wegen
Gefechten mit der libanesischen hisbolla
Miliz einen schönen guten Abend Michael
zu dir was hast du heute dort in der
Region festgest stellt erlebt wie ist
die Stimmung
aktuell ja von Stimmung kann man nicht
sprechen denn es gibt keine Menschen die
eine Stimmung haben könnte kreatchmona
ist menschenleer heute morgen kam der
Räumungsbefehl auch für die größte Stadt
hier im Norden wie schon für die anderen
Dörfer und Ortschaften entlang der
libanesischen Grenze hier gibt es
eigentlich nur noch Soldaten die ihre
Stellung bezogen haben den ganzen Tag
über gab es heftige Gefechte
mörserangriffe raketenangri
infiltrationsversuche der hbollah
vielleicht auch der heramas von der
libanesischen Seite wir hier in
kiriatchmona sind seit dem Nachmittag
hier und haben teilweise Minutentakt die
israelische Artillerie gehört die
zurückfeuert ich würde es immer noch als
Abtasten bezeichnen als Austesten der
gegnerischen Seite zu sagen wir sind da
wir könnten aber die entscheidende Phase
wird sein wenn denn die
lang diskutierte und immer wieder
angekündigte Bodenoffensive im Süden
tatsächlich beginnen würde weil dann
muss ich die hzbollah die letztendlich
vom Iran gesteuert wird und auch der
Iran entscheiden ob sie hier im Norden
tatsächlich einen weiteren Krieg mit
Israel führen wollen mhm du hast es
gerade angesprochen diese Bodenoffensive
wird jetzt schon seit einer knappen
Woche angekündigt und das ZF
Politbarometer wartet heute mit
aktuellen Zahlen auf äh denn es wurde
mal nachgefragt bei den Menschen in
Deutschland wie gerechtfertigt die
Deutschen eine israelische
Bodenoffensive sehen wir können uns das
mal ganz kurz anschauen eine knappe
Mehrheit spricht sich dagegen aus
41% sagen Nein und 20% sind
unentschlossen also das zeigt schon eine
recht unsichere Meinung vieler Menschen
in Deutschland auf wie sehen das die
Israelis stehen die hinter den Plänen
ihres
Verteidigungsministeriums ja ich habe
auch schon die ganze Zeit darauf
gewartet dass das Politbarometer mal
hier eine Umfrage macht weil das ist
natürlich eine interessante Frage wie
stehen eigentlich die Israelis dazu
heute gab es dann tatsächlich eine
ernstzunehmende Umfrage einer
israelischen Tageszeitung und danach
unterstützen 65% also fast zwei Drittel
der Israelis eine Bodenoffensive und 80%
sagen Premierminister netannaho muss die
Verantwortung dafür übernehmen was am 7
Oktober passiert ist für das Versagen
der israelischen
sicherheitsstreitkräfte wir haben gerade
schon oder bei uns trudeln gerade schon
die ersten Fragen und Kommentare unserer
User ein Michael eine Frage vielleicht
kannst du dazu was sagen von
AA wenn eine Bodenoffensive tatsächlich
starten sollte und sie ist ja jetzt
schon länger angekündigt wie werden die
arabischen Israelis in Israel
reagieren das ist eine sehr gute Frage
denn im letzten Krieg der deutlich
weniger intensiv war im Mai 2021
als nur nur in Anführungsstrichen
Raketen flogen aus dem Gazastreifen und
natürlich auch ein wieder heftiges
Bombardement der israelisinsätze da gab
es hier schon fast bürgerkriegsähnliche
Zustände die arabische Bevölkerung die
sich schon seit langem hier als Bürger
zweiter Klasse in Israel sieht hat
teilweise revoltiert es gab aber auch
Rechtsextreme Siedlergruppen die dagegen
gehalten haben es gab straßenschlachte
jede Menge Zusammenstöße das alles haben
wir bisher nicht gesehen ich lebe selber
in so einem gemischten Stadtteil in
Jaffa das war damals in NoGo area wo ich
mich abends nachdem ich gearbeitet hatte
nur mit größter Vorsicht wieder zurück
in mein Apartment bewegen konnte das
alles gibt es bisher nicht auch das
Westjordanland bleibt bisher relativ
ruhig allerdings sind dort auch fast 600
äh ähm als Terror verdächtig
Menschen verhaftet worden also das kann
natürlich auch eine Rolle spielen aber
tatsächlich ist es so dass es bisher
ruhig geblieben ist und ob das bei einer
Bodenoffensive so bleibt die Hamas
fordert ja ständig dazu auf dass sich
alle Araber egal ob in Israel oder in
der arabischen Welt quasi gegen Israel
erheben sollen aktuelle Einschätzungen
aus dem Norden Israels von unserem
Reporter Michael beeverunge Michael
guten Abend zu dir danke schön für die
Zeit danke fürs Gespräch
ja diese Woche war vor allem von vielen
Besuchen geprägt in Israel Staats- und
Regierungschefs sind ein und ausgeflogen
gefühlt unter anderem der US-Präsident
Joe Biden war zu Gast auch Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz diplomatische Gespräche
standen da an der Tagesordnung und ob
die was gebracht haben ob die überhaupt
noch in diesem Stadium des Konflikts
sinnvoll nützlich sind das wollen wir
jetzt klären mit dem nahostexperten
Daniel Gerlach er ist mir zugeschaltet
in unserem Hauptstadtstudio guten Abend
nach Berlin zu Ihnen Herr Gerach ja
hallo nach meins es gab viele
diplomatische Bemühungen immer noch
diplomatische Bemühungen ähm haben die
Besuche von beiden und Scholz irgendwie
was schon bewirken können ihrer Meinung
nach was den Besuch von Bundeskanzler
Scholz anbetrifft weiß ich das nicht
genau beim Besuch von Joe Biden habe ich
den Eindruck ja ähm ich glaube die
Amerikaner hatten zwei Ziele oder
vielleicht drei das eine war dass sie
ein deutliches Zeichen setzen wollten
dass wer auch immer in diesen Krieg
jetzt von außen noch eingreifen möchte
namentlich z.B die Boller mit
amerikanischer Antwort rechnen muss und
deswegen haben sie die Flugzeugträger in
das wöstliche Mittelmeer geschafft
gleichzeitig beiden nach Israel gefahren
und hat hat nach meinem Eindruck schon
versucht Netanyahu
gut zuzureden und davon abzubbringen
dass er unüberlegte Schritte aus dem aus
der Verzweiflung aus der Wut aus dem
ja aus dem letztendlich aus Hass auch
trifft und jetzt vielleicht nicht zu
große Risiken eingeht mit einer schlecht
geplanten Bodenoffensive nach Gaza er
hat sehr bedachte Worte gewählt er hat
z.B gesagt ähm wir haben viele Fehler
gemacht nach 9/11 weil wir einfach
wütend und verzweifelt waren und tut
macht diese Fehler nicht und das ist
schon ganz interessantes Statement
gewesen also er hat offensichtlich den
Eindruck gehabt er muss da noch mal
einen drauflegen aber beiden hat
natürlich auch ein anderes Ziel gehabt
und das ist die Befreiung oder zumindest
die Sorge um das Schicksal der Geiseln
der amerikanischen Geiseln denn
zumindest die amerikanischen
Staatsbürger unter den israelischen
Geiseln äh in Gaza die möchte er
natürlich gerne nach Hause holen und ich
glaube darauf konzentrieren sich viele
der Bemühung und ich kann mir vorstellen
dass ich darauf auch auf die humanitäre
Hilfe aber insbesondere auf das
Schicksal der Geiseln auch jetzt die
deutsche Diplomatie maßgeblich
konzentriert mhm nun wurde kurzfristig
ab morgen oder es wird kurzfristig ab
morgen in Cairo ein sogenannter
Friedensgipfel anberaumt arabische und
westliche Staaten wollen da morgen über
mögliche eindämmungen des Konflikts
beraten dennoch sehen viele Politiker
keine wirkliche Alternative zu einer
israelischen bodenofens sie wie schätzen
Sie das ein gibt's auf Ebene der
Diplomatie überhaupt noch
Erfolgschancen na ich entwerfe jetzt mal
ein optimistisches Szenario aber das ist
jetzt nicht mein Szenario sondern das
ist etwas was ich aus arabischen
diplomatischen Kreisen gehört habe und
zwar sehr konkret wenn es gelingen
sollte innerhalb der nächsten Stunden
vielleicht sogar vielleicht sogar vor
Eröffnung oder zuur Eröffnung dieses
sogenannten
friedensgipfels Geiseln aus Gaza zu
befreien wenn es gelingt die hamaskräfte
die diese Geiseln festhalten davon zu
überzeugen dass sie guten Willen zeigen
sollen dann wäre das ein unglaublich
großer Erfolg und auch Vertrauensbeweis
für die qataris die die entscheidende
mediationsmacht anscheinend gerade in
der Kommunikation zwischen Israel und
der Hamas sind die Israelis haben aber
gleichzeitig gesagt sie würden nichts
dafür im Gegenzug geben sie lassen sich
nicht erpressen und sie führen keine
Verhandlungen aber manchmal ist ja
gerade das auch ein eine Möglichkeit
dann trotzdem im Geheimen geheimen
Verhandlungen zu führen wenn man sich
darauf verlassen kann dass der media at
das für sich behält und eben nicht nach
außen trägt dass vielleicht doch ein
Arrangement stattfindet immerhin haben
wir gesehen dass die israelische
Bodenoffensive verzögert wurde aus
taktischen Gründen weil die israelische
Armee vielleicht sich noch nicht bereit
fühlte oder weil man eben noch abwarten
wollte wie andere Akteure wie hbollah
und Iran reagieren es kann aber auch
sein dass diese Verzögerung der
Bodenoffensive etwas mit den Geiseln zu
tun hat und damit dass man vielleicht
erwartet dass wenigstens die Zivilisten
unter den Geiseln freigelassen werden
die Kataris
lassen verlauten über diplomatische
Kanäle dass sie durchaus eine
realistische Chance sehen die Zivilisten
unter den Geiseln freiubekommen das
heißt diejenigen die nicht unmittelbare
Angehörige des Militärs des israelischen
Militärs sind aber das ist der Waage ich
glaube wenn die qataris hier Wort halten
und und eben Optimismus auch beweisen
können dann wird das ja innerhalb dieses
Wochenendes passieren wo wir gerade
schon auf der politischen Ebene sind
Herr Gerlach unser Recht eine Frage von
unserem Zuschauer Alexander Schulz er
will wissen wie politisch riskant ist
der der Angriff Israels auf den
Gazastreifen der mögliche Angriff der
Angriff auf den oder der der die
Bodenoffensive ist sehr riskant auf der
einen Seite ist sie riskant wenn man sie
durchführt auf der anderen Seite wenn
man sie nicht durchführt denn Israel hat
sie versprochen hat seinen seinen
eigenen staatsbürern gesagt wir werden
das machen wir werden die Macht der
Hamas für alle Zeiten brechen wir werden
dafür sorgen dass sie nie wieder in der
Lage ist das zu tun was sie am 7 Oktober
getan hat vielleicht hat sie es gar
nicht intendiert es in diesem in diesem
Umfang zu tun und war selbst überrascht
von dem Ausmaß äh ihres
ihres sogenannten Erfolges aus eigener
Sicht aber in jedem Fall hat sie etwas
getan was unvergleichbar ist in der
Geschichte Israels ein Massaker
verrichtet das eben eine Antwort
benötigt und Israel hat die israelische
Führung hat das zugesagt auf der anderen
Seite weiß die israelische Führung auch
wenn Sie eine Bodenoffensive
insbesondere im Norden des Gazastreifens
durchführt dann wird sie natürlich in
ein also kann es sein dass sie in einen
Hinterhalt gerät sie hat die Wahl
entweder sämtliche hohen Gebäude in der
Stadt zu zerstören von denen aus sie
beschossen werden können oder eben
reinzugehen und damit eben unheimlich
viel zivile Infrastruktur zu zerstören
oder eben reinzugehen und das Risiko in
Kauf zu nehmen dass man von allen Seiten
von der Hamas eben belagert wird denn
darauf haben sich die Hamas und ihre
Verbündeten vorbereitet und letztendlich
haben sie auch
wäre das ihr ihr letzter Schritt also
Sie haben ja auch keine andere
Alternative anderweitig davon zuomen
deswegen werden sie da alles in die
Schlacht werfen was sie haben und das
ist natürlich ein Szenario äh das gut
überlegt sein will äh denn wenn sich die
israelische Armee jetzt verzetteln würde
im Häuserkampf und eben nicht schnell zu
erfolgen käme würde das nicht nur die
die zivilen Opfer in die Höhe treiben
denn die Leute werden nicht auf Dauer
aus dem Gazastreifen verschwinden es
wird möglicherweise auch dann andere
Akteure animieren einzugreifen wie dies
Bolla denn wenn Israel da Schwäche zeigt
dann ist die Verführung groß für die
isbolla eben der Hamas zu Hilfe zu allen
was vielleicht nicht so groß ist wenn
Israel Stärke zeigt und das ist das
dilemmer in dem man sich befindet genau
dann hätte man den sogenannten zwei
frontenkrieg der ja von Experten schon
prognostiziert wird sollte diese
Bodenoffensive tatsächlich wie
angekündigt stattfinden blicken wir noch
zum Abschluss schnell mal auf die
Zivilbevölkerung
was hätte das denn für die Menschen
konkret in Israel und in Gaza für
Konsequenzen na ja es wurde ja gesagt
dass mehrere hunderttausend da variieren
die Zahlen Palästinenser aus dem Norden
des Gazastreifens also aus dem Umfeld
von gazastadt eben in den Süden geflohen
sein
m viele Menschen in Gaza und über auch
in anderen Teilen der palästinensischen
Gebiete sind aus gutem Grund der Ansicht
wenn sie einmal ihre Häuser aufgeben
wenn sie einmal ihr Land verlassen dann
sind sie Flüchtlinge und dann müssen Sie
damit rechnen dass sie nie wieder da
dorthin zurückkehren das ist die
Erfahrung die viele Palästinenser
Familien gemacht haben und das steckt in
den Menschen sehr tief drin das heißt
also man wird sich nicht vertreiben
lassen und das gilt natürlich noch viel
krasser für das Westjordanland auch die
Nachbarstaaten Ägypten und Jordanien
haben gesagt dass sie dieses Szenario
auf keinen Fall akzeptieren werden das
heißt wenn es tatsächlich dann einen
dreifrontenkrieg wäre wenn nämlich im
westjordan Land in Gaza und in Libanon
gekämpft würde dann glaube ich dann
hätten die Israelis mit sehr sehr
heftigem bewaffneten Widerstand zu
rechnen und das müssen sie einpreisen
deswegen ist wahrscheinlich das das das
günstigste Szenario dass sie eine
gesichtswahende bodenintervention machen
in Gaza
allerdings nicht zu groß dass sie einige
Erfolge erzielen aber dann eben doch
wieder hoffen dass es in irgendeiner
Form eine Verhandlungslösung unter
Einbindung der arabischen Staaten gibt
von der keiner weiß wie sie aussieht
insofern beneide ich die Leute nicht die
da die politischen militärischen
Entscheidungen treffen Einschätzungen
vom narostexperten Daniel Gerlach
zugeschaltet aus Berlin Herr Gerlach
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit danke für das
Gespräch ja danke
ihnen Israels Bodenoffensive wie groß
ist das Risiko welche Risiken wirkt das
das fragen wir uns heute bei ZDF heute
live und das israelische Militär wird
bei einer Bodenoffensive in jedem Fall
in Gaza ein Gebiet betreten das ein
weitläufiges Tunnelsystem auszeichnet
hunderte Kilometer lang sehr verwinkelt
sehr eng bietet es Verstecke für
Terroristen wir wollen mal kurz darauf
blicken was Israels Soldaten bei einer
möglichen Bodenoffensive da erwarten
dürfte unterhalb von Gaza nutzt die
Hammers ein weit verzweigtes
Tunnelsystem oben normale Straßen und
Wohnungen darunter bis zu 40 m tief
unter der Erde sollen Gänge verlaufen
das tunnelnetz soll bis zu 500 km lang
sein damit wäre es mehr als dreimal so
groß wie das u-bahnetz in Berlin und
könnte sogar bis nach Ägypten und Israel
reichen die Eingänge befinden sich
teilweise auf freien Feldern in Häusern
oder auch unter Schulen einige dieser
Tunnel sind sehr gut ausgebaut und mit
Beton ausgekleidet dort sollen die Hamas
Terroristen sogar mit Motorrädern fahren
können andere Gänge sind hingegen schmal
und Einsturz gefährdet schon früher
wurden durch Tunnel unterhalb von Gaser
Lebensmittel und Waffen geschmuggelt
heute benutzt die Hammers die
unterirdisch vor allem als Waffenlager
für Hinterhalte und um Anschläge
auszuführen t ein einmaliges Konstrukt
dieses tunnelgebiet hunderte Kilometer
lang unter dem palästinensischen Gebiet
welche
Herausforderungen bietet das oder welche
Gefahren auch für die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten aus Israel das wollen wir jetzt
kären mit dem militäranalysten hendrimel
ein schön guten
Abend hallo schön guten
Abend mus man sich das dann vorstellen
sie haben militärische Expertise wenn
man jetzt als externer Soldat solch ein
Gebiet betritt
nicht wirklich weiß wie das konstruiert
ist die Einheimischen Terroristen aber
vielleicht schon geht das so einfach zu
knacken nein einfach zu knacken geht das
nicht
auch wenn ich ein wenig relativieren
möchte dass die israelischen Soldaten
keine Kenntnisse über die urbanen und
suburbanen Strukturen
in Gazastreifen haben die haben sie sie
haben Kampferfahrung zuletzt in einem
größeren Umfang 201 144 als israelische
Streitkräfte genau diese tundelsysteme
von denen sie gerade im Beitrag
gesprochen haben versucht haben zu
lukalisieren und zu zerstören
nichtsdestotrotz befinden sich die
israelischen Streitkräfte wenn Sie sich
für eine
Bodenoffensive entscheiden in einem
sogenannten 360° Umfeld das heißt Sie
müssen entgegen ähm einfacherer
Strukturen wie sie jetzt jetzt z.B auf
freiem Feld in der Ukraine sehen nicht
nur nach vorne nach rechts und nach
links gucken sie müssen nach oben
schauen die angesprochenen teilweise
zehnstöckigen Gebäude sie müssen hinter
sich schauen weil die ähm Hamas Kämpfer
die angesprochenen Tunnel nicht nur zum
Ausweichen nutzen werden sondern auch
nutzen können um hinter die
israelischen Kräfte zu kommen und sie
aus dem Rücken anzugreifen und Sie
müssen natürlich auch nach unten schauen
in die Tunnelsystem
mhm es klingt aber von der Ausgangslage
schon danach dass die Hamas Heimvorteil
hätten
zumal diese Bodenoffensive jetzt auch
seit fast einer Woche schon angekündigt
wurde aber noch nicht in Gang gesetzt
wurde da können sich ja die Terroristen
natürlich drauf
vorbereiten ja der Verteidiger hat in
egal welchem Gefecht egal in welcher
militärischen Operation in der Regel ein
Vorteil weil er sich natürlich
vorbereiten kann er kennt die Räume
besser in den er kämpfen möchte und in
der Regel legt er auch den exakten Ort
fest zumindest
wo das Gefecht aufgenommen wird
m grundsätzlich und das ist natürlich
ein relevanter Punkt der schon von
meinem vorretner sehr gut angesprochen
wurde sie müssen natürlich auch alle
strategischen Implikationen betrachten
also es geht nicht nur darum welche
Gefahren
haben die Soldaten mit welchen Gefahren
haben die Soldaten im gasercheifen zu
rechnen
der Beginn einer Militäroperation ist
nie eine rein militärische Entscheidung
sondern eine strategische Entscheidung
die
diplomatischen Begebenheiten die sich in
den letzten Tagen zugetragen haben unter
anderem die Verhandlungen über die
Freilassung von Geiseln die mögliche
Gefahr einer zweiten Front im Norden
Israels aber auch einer potenziellen
Gefahr aus dem Westjordanland wuren sehr
gut angesprochen in letzten Beitrag das
heißt wir dürfen nicht nur die
militärischen Aspekte sehen und uns
anhand dieser Parameter fragen warum hat
die Bodenoffensive noch nicht angefangen
sondern wir müssen das in einem
geostrategischen Gesamtkontext
betrachten sie sprechen die Strategien
an uns erreichen dazu Herr remel aktuell
etliche Fragen unserer Zuschauer z.B
Andrea fragt besteht die Gefahr dass
durch Raketen das Tunnelsystem
implodieren und zusammenfallen
könnte ja die Gefahr die Gefahr besteht
das ist auch eine Anwendung staktik die
vor allem die Amerikaner während des
Vietnamkrieges angewendet haben um diese
Tunnelsysteme zu zerstören das können
Sie natürlich in einem so stark bebauten
Gebiet einem sogenannten urbanen
Ballungsraum nur bedingt durchführen die
israelischen Streitkräfte haben
Präzisionsraketen die aufgeklärte
kelsysteme zerstören können aber
allgemein besteht natürlich auch nicht
nur durch raketengeschuss sondern auch
durch Kämpfe oder kontrollierte
Sprengung der hamaskämpfer immer die
Gefahr Tunnel einstürzen können während
israelische Soldaten diese gerade
freikämpfen es gibt auch die Möglichkeit
die beispielsweise der islamische Staat
in im Syrien Konflikt genutzt hat in
Mossul und raka sogenannte tunnelbomben
einzusetzen das heißt sie untergraben
wesentliche verbindungsruten wesentliche
Straßen die die israelischen
Streitkräfte brauchen um ihren nachschug
zu ihren Kampftruppen zu bringen und
zünden dann Sprengsätze große Menge an
Sprengstoff um diese wichtigen
verbindungsst Straßen dies sogenannten
groundlines communication zu zerstören
mhm eer schreibt das sind ja Reservisten
die zusammengezogen worduren wie gut
sind diese vorbereitet weil wir haben es
gerade gesehen diese Tunnelsysteme sind
schon sehr ausgeklügelt und ich kann mir
vorstellen militärisch sehr sehr
anspruchsvoll für
Soldaten ja ähm der Kampf und Tunneln
suburban Warfare ist mit das komplexeste
was sie einem Soldaten einer
militärischen ein deiner Kampf oder
Spezialeinheit zumuten können
man muss sich vergegen vergegenwärtigen
dass
all diese technischen Vorteile gerne
konventionelle Armee gegenüber einem
asymmetrisch kämpfenden Gegner wie die
Hamas in Tunneln entweder gar nicht
funktionieren oder nur mit speziellen
Material funktionieren also die Israelis
haben in den Tunneln keine
Luftunterstützung sie haben kaum
Aufklärungsmöglichkeiten
ihre Kommunikation funktioniert nur
bedingt also sie haben dort unten keinen
Satellitenempfang sie haben kein GPS das
heißt Sie können sich kaum orientieren
und es gibt nur sehr wenig
Spezialmaterial was sehr teuer ist und
mit dem Sicherheit nicht alle
israelischen Verbände die dort in diesen
Tunneln kämpfen werden ausgerüet sind
ich nenne mal ein einfaches Beispiel
nachtseegeräte funktionieren in der
Regel durch die Verstärkung von
Restlicht wenn sie in den israelischen
Tunneln in den Tunneln im Gasastreifen
das Licht ausmachen dann werden sie mit
herkömlichen nachtsehmitteln dort nichts
mehr sehen mhm wir hatten vor wenigen
Minuten schon über die über einen
möglichen zweif frontenkrieg gesprochen
wenn Israel tatsächlich mit der
Bodenoffensive beginnt dann könnte es
von mehreren Seiten angegriffen werden
das fragt sich auch Lopo das ist ja zu
befürchten dass Israel bei einer
Bodenoffensive von allen Seiten schreibt
der angegriffen wird
allgemein mal gefragt wenn es
tatsächlich zu einem Zweifrontenkrieg
käme wie gut ist denn das israelische
Militär aufgestellt kann es das
stemmen
ja das kann es stimmen dafür sind die
israelischen streiträfte auch
vorbereitet die bereits angesprochenen
Reservisten die innerhalb von 48 Stunden
mobilisiert worden sind über 360.000
sind nicht nur am gaserstreifen
zusammengezogen worden sondern stehen
auch an der Grenze zwischen Südlibanon
und Nordisrael aber auch im
Westjordanland wir reden davon im
Nordisrael von gut 100.000 israelischen
Soldaten Kampfverbänden die für genau
diese Situation aus diesem Grund dort äh
zusammengezogen worden sind der
ähm das Gebiet südlich der äh Grenze
wurde in einer Tiefe von 5 km evakuiert
um auch Voraussetzungen für eine
Militäroperation in diesem Gebiet zu
schaffen
ähm auch wenn das wahrscheinlich schwer
einzuschätzen ist Merlin fragt wie lange
würde denn eine Bodenoffensive allgemein
überhaupt
dauern
ja das ist wirklich schwer einzuschätzen
ähm das liegt grundsätzlich erstmal
daran ob die strategischen Parameter die
Einflussfaktoren
mit denen Israel sich gerade
auseinandersetzt gleich bleiben bleibt
die Unterstützung der Alliierten
bestehen vor allem die der USA die wie
auch bereits angesprochen zwei
flugzeugträgerkampfgruppen ins
Mittelmeer entsemmelt haben die eine
erhebliches abstreckungspotenzial vor
allem gegen über die hisbolla
generieren ähm das hat natürlich auch
was mit dem sogenannten Kampf um die
deutungsf Informationsraum zu tun ähm
wie wir als Gesellschaften mit
Informationen umgehen ähm beispielsweise
die vermeintliche Bombardierung eines
Krankenhauses ähm das sind alles
Einflussfaktoren die natürlich einen
strategischen Akteur einen politischen
Entscheidungsträger in der Frage
beeinflussen kann ich diese
Militäroffensive diese Operation
überhaupt aufrechterhalten also auch das
die Dauer natürlich wieder abhängig von
strategischen
Einflussfaktoren wenn Sie die
Militäroperation in einem luftlehen Raum
betrachten würden
kann man grundsätzlich davon ausgehen
dass auch eine solche komplexe
Militäroperation murbanen Raum in einer
Stadt die ungefähr so groß ist wie
Offenbach aber mit bedeutend mehr
Einwohnern selbst wenn die meisten von
evakuiert worden sind sehr sehr lange
dauern wird das ist keine
Militäroperation die Sie in wenigen
Tagen wahrscheinlich auch nicht in
wenigen Wochen erfolgreich zu Ende
bringen wenn das israelische Militär
wirklich sämtliche militärischen
Kapazitäten der heramas im Gazastreifen
zerstören soll und das ist der Auftrag
den das israelische Militär von der
Notstandsregierung bekommen hat zu
allerletzt her Remmel an sie auch noch
die Frage jetzt wo es seit knapp einer
Woche angekündigt wurde von dem von dem
israelischen Verteidigungsministerium
dass es eine Bodenoffensive geben soll
bislang gab es sie noch nicht erst war
das wetterschuld dann hat man auf
diplomatische ähm Wege noch gewartet ähm
glauben Sie dass es überhaupt zu einer
Bodenoffensive kommen
wird die militärischen Voraussetzungen
dafür sind gegeben äh die
Militäroperation wird seit mehreren
Tagen vor allem aus der Luft vorbereitet
äh durch Luftschläge aber auch durch
Artillerie ähm das Lagebild der
israelischen Streitkräfte über die ähm
Vorbereitung der Hamas werden sich in
den letzten Tagen verbessert haben es
kommt auch vermhr zu präzisionsschlägen
auf äh Stellung der Hamas vor allem
Kommandozentralen aber auch
abschussseinrichtung von Raketen also
die Grundvoraussetzungen für die
Militäroperation wurden geschaffen ähm
die vorgesehenen Einheiten befinden sich
in sogenannten verfügungsräumen das
heißt sie sind bereit ähm letztenendes
und das kann ich nur noch mal betonen
ist aber die Frage ob diese
Militäroperation stattfindet oder nicht
keine rein militärische sondern eine
strategische Frage die politische
Entscheidungsträger und insbesondere
Benjamin mit dann auch treffen müssen
das sind Einschätzungen von
militäranalysten Hendrik Remmel Herr
Remmel vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit danke
für das Gespräch sehr
gerne und das war unsere heutige Sendung
ZDF heute live wir danken für euer
Interesse für all eure Fragen und
Kommentare und sagen tschüss bis zum
nächsten
Mal